it's clear high inflation isn't going
away anytime soon but who's to blame
many are pointing the finger president
biden others at fed share jerome powell
and still others at large corporations
i'm going to explain what inflation
really is how it works and who's to
blame for the fastest price increases
we've seen in decades
let's get into it inflation simply means
that prices are being inflated or rising
and that the pace of that increase is
moving quickly this is measured by
economists who track the price of goods
and services from one month to the next
and compare it to previous periods and
thus we can see how today's inflation
stacks up inflation is a bit like a
snowball rolling downhill as prices
start to rise for some items other items
that use those items and businesses that
rely on them start to raise their prices
as well if this gets out of hand you can
start to see runaway inflation where
prices rise by hundreds or even
thousands of percentage points in a year
but that's extremely rare and generally
happens when governments and central
banks make big mistakes but even
moderately high inflation has a culprit
and in the u.s inflation is rising at an
8.6 annual rate the fastest it has been
in 40 years so who's to blame lots of
people point the finger at federal
reserve chair jerome powell legendary
economist milton friedman famously said
inflation is always and everywhere a
monetary phenomenon and it's true the
fed pumped 120 billion dollars a month
into the u.s economy for years swelling
its balance sheet to more than eight
trillion dollars and around half of that
came after march 2020 but prior to 2020
the fed had used this strategy and
inflation remained very low after 2020
though the fed kept interest rates near
zero despite trillions in stimulus
spending by the federal government they
are just now beginning to raise interest
rates which increases the cost of
borrowing and slows down the economy in
an effort to reign in price increases
but rates are still negative today when
accounting for inflation then there's
the president and the truth is the
person in the oval office deserves some
blame president joe biden signed the
american rescue plan which the
congressional budget office said would
add 1.85 trillion dollars to the u.s
budget deficit and then there's former
president donald trump who signed the
2.3 trillion cares act and the 900
billion consolidated appropriations act
in december one way to think of
inflation is too much money chasing too
few goods and by providing trillions of
dollars in money to american households
the president and congress helped tip
the scales on inflation trump also
nominated powell to his role as fed
chair and biden renominated him last
year so even if inflation is simply a
monetary phenomenon the president picks
the person in charge of monetary policy
and therefore has to take a little bit
of the blame earnings reports show that
s p 500 companies on average are raising
their prices by about 20 percent more
than the rate of inflation for wholesale
prices that means that as the prices for
their inputs have increased they've
raised the prices by a lot more their
profit margins are also at record highs
so a good bit of inflation is due to big
companies don't forget kovid 19 the war
in ukraine and other price shocks have
played a big role and finally there's us
regular working people everyday
americans push up inflation in two ways
first by demanding higher wages from
their employer putting pressure on
companies to raise prices to account for
rising labor costs and second we keep
paying higher prices if consumers stayed
home and refused to pay companies
profits would take a beating and they'd
be forced to bring down their prices
but because individuals keep spending
companies keep pushing prices up the
bottom line is no one person or entity
is entirely responsible for inflation
and in fact you're partially responsible
too the great j cole reminds us they say
time is money but really it's not if we
ever go broke time is all we got
that's all for now see you next time
you